hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to a new series called youtube
gear it's all about gear
for youtube so one of the most common
questions that i get personally besides
like what phone should i get or what
tablet should i get is i want to start
making videos what type of gear should i
look to to get on camera and start
making my own so i've had a series in
the past that actually helped people to
kind of sort of get started with making
a youtube channel but this whole series
idea is to be able to feature awesome
gear and show cool quality versatile
stuff that will actually help you make
content now it's not all about the gear
that's an important thing to note it's
obviously content first the stuff you
make videos about is really what matters
and that's the whole reason to start a
youtube channel but having quality
versatile
working gear is actually something
that's surprisingly important and i'm a
gear head anyway so it kind of plays to
the ability to show off cool tech and
things like that so content first but if
you have gear that'll help you out that
works too all right so this is the first
piece of gear
that i am featuring uh in this playlist
or series if you don't know what it is
it might look a little bit weird this is
a microphone it has its own desktop
stand this is called the blue
yeti pro now that it's around black
friday you'll see microphones and stuff
from blue and a bunch of others going
from way lower prices i saw this guy
this blackout edition uh for somewhere
around 100 bucks which is way less than
what i paid for it a while ago and this
is also sort of like a youtube classic
microphone i was using this microphone
full time like three
four even five years ago it showed up in
videos i think i made an entire video
all about it i think it was the silver
version but yeah this thing is tried and
true and i feel like it's about time i
recommend it so this is what it looks
like if you haven't seen a microphone
like this before like i said it has a
built-in stand it articulates to face
your mouth exactly and it's got a whole
bunch of features that make it a little
bit different from a normal mic and
that's why it costs more so underneath
this cover here it's not just one
microphone there are three different
microphones facing a bunch of different
directions and it's covered here and
there's a switch on the back that you
can see that'll allow you to switch
between a bunch of different recording
patterns for different uses so there's
stereo mode there's omnidirectional mode
nice good quality switch to switch
between them a cardioid mode and a
bi-directional cardioid mode will just
pick up what's directly in front of the
microphone so if i'm just talking to it
i'm making a video and i want to just
record my own voice it'll cancel what's
behind the mic and just pick me up i'll
give a sound quality test in a second
but if you're doing an interview or
something and there was someone on the
other side of the microphone you could
use this mic as well pick up the voice
on the other side your own voice but
cancel out the sides so you can see how
it can be a little bit more versatile
than just one mic caps around the front
is a physical
mute switch so if you want to mute
yourself that's neat and then a
headphone volume knob which is because
this microphone has a headphone jack at
the bottom latency free monitoring of
your own audio so this is a usb mic i'm
going to plug it into this surface book
here it lights up this mute button
lights up so that's pretty cool i have
audacity
on this machine i use audacity which is
a free piece of software and i've used
it for
like seven years i don't use adobe
audition or anything fancy audacity just
lets me pick the input source pick the
quality level and then record audio and
that's all i need to do
so right now
right now you should be listening to the
quality of the yeti pro and i can
actually switch the gain if i want to
change the gain gain up or gain down it
seems like the volume is about right and
you can obviously now tell the
difference between the mic i've been
using which is a shotgun microphone
right up here made by sennheiser and
this yeti pro it's pretty clean i mean
compared to what you could get in a
microphone for a hundred bucks or 120
bucks like five years ago this is a lot
better sounding than something you could
get for that price this is also on the
cardioid pattern it would sound
different if i put it in like
bi-directional
switch it live now i'm in
bi-directional so you can hear
everything behind the microphone you
probably won't hear things to the sides
of it and you can hear my own voice for
the sake of this i'm going to go back to
cardioid i really like the the hard
switch it's quality it's all made of
metal the whole thing is metal so there
you go guys that's the blue yeti pro and
that's youtube gear number one now if
you have any other suggestions for
pieces of youtube gear whether it's
lenses or cameras or microphones or
accessories basically any piece of gear
related to making videos let me know get
at me because that's the kind of stuff i
want to feature in these future episodes
and also every single time i do a
youtube gear video whatever i talk about
in the video i'm going to be giving away
on twitter follow me on twitter mkbhd
and within like 24 hours of this video
going live there will be a giveaway post
where you can pick up this exact
microphone that i'm using in this video
right here and probably get started on a
youtube channel of your own so that's
been it youtube gear is now a thing dope
tech is now a thing we're branching out
a little bit more hopefully you guys
enjoy this kind of stuff and if you do
let me know by giving a thumbs up below
thanks for watching and i'll talk to you
guys in the next one
peace